As we go to our next game,
AskReddit: Sex Ed Edition.
Redditor Mollymonkey101 posted
this fascinating query
in-in AskReddit:
"Sex Ed teachers of reddit,
what is the stupidest question
you've ever gotten?"
Among the avalanche of gems
was this one: "It's fun, right?"
Um... yes,
but not with an alcoholic clown
at a Super Bowl party,
I think would be the answer.
So, comedians, I want you to ask
even dumber sex ed questions
in 60 seconds. And begin.
Uh, Jim.
I have two girls,
but I don't have a cup.
-Will a mug work?
-Points.
Nikki.
How old are balls?
Points.
Kevin.
Does it count as cheating
if it's just oral
and you're related?
Poi...
Points.
Jim Jefferies.
My friend says
that woman can have orgasms.
Is he gay or just stupid?
Points. Kevin.
Where in the Bible does it say
that Jesus is cool
with the butt stuff?
Points. Nikki Glaser.
Who wins?
Points.
Kevin.
How much blood should be
in the ejaculate?
A gallon?
Is it... is it...
No, seriously.
If it's... Is it more
than a gallon, is that bad?
More than a gallon. I think
less than a gallon's okay.
-More than a gallon's bad.
Points. -All right, okay, good.